how do we convert a non-terminating
recurring decimal to the form p by q
take the number 0.3 with a bar over 3.
how do we get this in the form p by q
it's simple but interesting
let's equate x with 0.3 bar
you will know soon as to why we're doing
this
a bar over 3 means x equals 0.3333
and so on let this be our first equation
there's only one way in which we can
convert this into a fraction
it's by eliminating of the recurring
decimal
eliminating this 3 3 3 3 and so on how
do we eliminate it here's the most
important step
we multiply both sides of this equation
by 10.
that gives us 10x equals 3.3333
and so on let this be our second
equation
now we have two equations with us
can we eliminate this point 3333
think about it
how about we subtract this equation from
this one
so let's write the first equation here
x equals 0.3333
and so on
we subtract the left-hand sides and the
right-hand sides
10x minus x gives us nine x
and three point three three three three
minus zero point three three three three
gives us three
we finally managed to eliminate the
recurring decimal
we have just three on the right hand
side now
transposing 9 to the right hand side we
get x equal to 3 by 9
which equals 1 by 3.
here we converted our recurring decimal
to the rational number form p by q
remember
our ultimate aim is to eliminate the
recurring decimal
but what if we had a mixed recurring
decimal like
0.75 with a bar over 5.
here x would equal 0.75
and so on the digit 7 is not repeated
let this be our first equation
to convert this into p by q form we have
to eliminate 5 5 5 5 which is the
recurring part
this one's interesting
let's multiply both sides of the first
equation by 10.
that gives us 10x equals
7.5555 and so on
let this be our second equation
now tax your brain a little
if we subtract this from this
will we eliminate 5 5 5 and so on
the only way that can happen is if we
have two equations which have just the
recurring part after the decimal
like in the previous example we had 3 3
3 3 after the decimal point
how do we manage to get a 5 5 5 5 after
the decimal point in two equations here
it's simple we multiply equation 1 with
that gives us 100 x equals 75.5555
and so on
so now we have two equations which have
just five five five five after the
decimal point
let's subtract this equation from this
one
one hundred x minus ten x equals ninety
x on the left hand side
and this minus this will equal 68.
we can see that getting the part after
the decimal same allows us to just
subtract it out so this actually equaled
75 minus 7.
transposing 90 to the other side x would
equal 68 by 90 which can be reduced to
34 by 45
so that's how we converted a mixed
recurring decimal to the form p by q
it's simple just aim to get the
recurring part after the decimal and
you're done
there are two more parts based on
conversion of non-terminating recurring
decimals to the form p by q
make sure you watch them too
you